artificial intelligence and machine
learning continue to be among the most
Indian skills in various Industries to
stay ahead of the curve in an
increasingly data driven world the use
of a and ml Technologies has become
ubiquitous are more prevalent in various
sectors like healthcare Finance retail
e-commerce manufacturing and many more
businesses are increasingly leveraging
these Technologies to automate tasks and
processes gain insights create
Innovative products and services and
improve efficiency by cost effective
Solutions learning Ai and ml can provide
you with valuable skills that are high
in demand and can help you access in
various job opportunities like data
scientist AI developer ml engineer
business analyst NLP engineer and many
more at the moment AI engineering is one
of the most lucrative career paths in
the world the age of Market has been
growing at a phenomenal rate for some
time now ai Engineers can earn average
salary of well over 120 000 annually in
the USA according to glass door the
average national salary is about one ten
thousand dollars and the highest salary
is one fifty thousand dollars now the
entry level annual average AI engineer
salary in India is around 10 lakhs which
is significantly higher than the average
salary of any engineering graduate so
choosing the right course to excel in
the field of AI and ml can be a
challenging task with so many options
available out there in the market how do
you know which one is right for you well
we are here to help you in this video
we'll discuss the top 5 best courses on
AI and machine learning in 2023 from
Hands-On projects to expert instructions
these courses offer a comprehensive
learning experience that can help you
achieve your career goals in Ai and ml
so without any further Ado let's dive in
and explore the best courses offered by
simply learn on machine learning and AI
first on the list we have post
graduation program in Ai and machine
learning this course is designed for you
to acquire solid foundation and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
Concepts making it an excellent choice
for individuals looking to build career
in Ai and ml nation and in-depth
knowledge on AI and machine learning
Concepts making it an excellent choice
for individuals looking to build a
career in Ai and ml the post-graduate
program in AIML by simply learn covers a
wide range of topics and provides
hands-on experience in developing Ai and
ml solutions for professionals who want
to upgrade their skills and private to a
career in the field of Ain ml this
course features master classes by Purdue
faculty and IBM experts exclusive
hackathons to help you master various
skills like statistics python supervised
learning neural networks NLP and much
more by covering tools and techniques
like numpy pandas python sci-fi along
with amazing industry projects so what
is stopping you from building your
future in Ai and ml Android course link
is in the description box below next on
the list we have ai and machine learning
bootcamp this Ai and machine learning
bootcamp program in collaboration with
Caltech University will help you develop
your career as an expert in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the A
and ml bootcamp offers master classes by
Caltech professors live classes thought
by industry experts interactive labs and
projects relevant to the industry this
bootcamp offers caltex academic
Excellence simple lunch career
assistance campus immersion and hands-on
experience this Ai and ml bootcamp will
help you get noticed by top hiring
companies help you in the industry
relevant Capstone projects the AI and
machine learning bootcamp at Caltech is
the best option for anyone wishing to
get a Competitive Edge in the air of
Cutting Edge Technologies this boot camp
offers a complete understanding of AI
based Technologies like machine learning
natural language processing deep
learning speech recognization
reinforcement learning and much more
this course covers tools and techniques
like python tensorflow care as
matplotlib and many more along with
industry projects like social media
e-commerce manufacturing epic Healthcare
and many more Amazing projects choosing
this bootcamp can get you hired by
Renault companies like Microsoft Google
IBM Amazon Samsung and Adobe this
bootcamp has benefited many aspiring Ai
and ml engineers and professionals some
of them have shared their testimonies
you can look at their feedback on the
course page the link to which is in the
description box below next course that
we are going to come across is
professional certification course in Ai
and machine learning this professional
certificate course in Ai and machine
learning by IIT kanpur is a
comprehensive program that provides a
Learners with a deep understanding of
fundamental concepts and practical
applications of AI and ml this course is
designed for working professionals
graduates and undergraduates who want to
upskill and build a career in Ai and ml
some of the key features of this program
include masterclass delivered by
distinguished IIT kanpur faculty caption
projects in various domains eight times
higher interaction in live online
classes by industry experts and much
more the course is delivered to online
lectures video tutorials and Hands-On
assignments Learners will have the
opportunity to work on real projects
that allow them to apply their skills
and knowledge to solve tactical problems
this course also covers tools and
techniques like python tensorflow nltk
Keras and much more along with industry
projects like Twitter social media
Amazon e-commerce and many more Amazing
projects that you can work on choosing
this course can get you hired by Renault
companies like Google Amazon LinkedIn
Adobe and average salary hike of 70
percent and upon completion of this
course Learners will receive a
professional certificate from IIT kanpur
which will enhance their career
prospects in the field of AI and ml
fourth on the list we have Caltech
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning this Caltech postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning
offered by simply learn is an online
program designed to provide students
with a comprehensive understanding of AI
and machine learning Concepts tools and
its techniques this program is created
in collaboration with Caltech ctme and
IBM and it is designed to provide
Learners with a strong foundation in Ai
and machine learning the program covers
various topics such as data science
statistics deep learning computer vision
NLP and help you gain write skills on
various tools such as Keras marketlab
tensorflow Django and mini mode
furthermore the curriculum is structured
around interactive online classes live
sessions with industry experts and
Hands-On projects as well the program
also includes access to simple and
learning management system which
provides students with additional
resources such as practice exercises
quizzes and other simulations overall
the Celtic postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning offered by
simplylearn is a well-structured and
comprehensive program that can help you
gain expertise in Ai and machine
learning Concepts and enhance your
career prospects in this field so what
are you waiting for hurry up in the
Caltech postgraduate program mean a and
ML and create your own successful career
link is in the description box below and
finally on the list we have Masters in
artificial intelligence program this
master's program in artificial
intelligence is one of the sought after
courses offered by simply learn this
artificial intelligence master program
in collaboration with IBM introduces
students to Blended learning and
prepares them to be specialist in Ai and
machine learning this program will teach
you the necessary skills you need to
become an AI expert and land in your
dream job this course covers the basic
fundamentals of Python programming
languages and its popular libraries like
numpy pandas from the scratch to some
advanced level topics like machine
learning algorithms deep learning NLP
computer vision and AI deployment by
covering some important tools like Keras
tensorflow sci-fi and many more so what
else can you expect from this program
well this course also includes three
Capstone projects and 12 industry
relevant projects from the likes of
Amazon Walmart Mercedes Uber and many
more immersive learning experience eight
times higher live interaction in live a
online classes delivered by seasoned
trainers and Industry experts sounds
interesting right so what are you
waiting for don't miss out this chance
to take your carry to the next level
enroll in our artificial intelligence
Masters program course today and start
your journey to become an AI expert the
link is added in the description box and
comment section below so with this we
have come to the end of top 5 courses on
machine learning and AI I hope the video
was informative and interesting if you
have any queries regarding any of the
courses covered in this video or need
any other help then please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to help resolve all your
queries at the earliest and don't forget
to subscribe to Simply learn for more
such amazing content until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here